What's up everybody?
I'm here in the kitchen in LA with my older brother, Josh.
It's Chinese New Year and growing up we used to always cook Chinese food...
...then bring it to a potluck.
So, basically what we're going to do is, once we're done cooking this food,...
...we're going to the nearby park, eat the food with some friends,...
...and celebrate Chinese New Year.
A big misconception about celebrities, or whatever, athletes or entertainers...
...is that we have it all together.
And then a big misconception about homelessness or homeless people is that...
...they have nothing, like, together.
People believe that those who are homeless don't want to do better for themselves.
That they don't want to work or don't want to go to school...
...or be closer to their family when, in reality, that's not true at all.
I know, before I ended up on the streets, I kind of thought,...
...well, these people must be all out here because they screwed up.
People shouldn't be so hasty to judge and put people in categories...
...because, what they say, "Never judge a book by the cover."
So, the tradition for Chinese New Year is you always give a red envelope.
It's supposed to, like, bring in the New Year and everything...
...so, we got some for you guys.
No worries.
You heard it from them,...
...there are a lot of assumptions about homeless people:...
...it must be drugs, it must be alcohol, it must be some crime.
But a lot of it oftentimes is things outside their control that are happening...
...and so I just think it's a valuable thing to do,...
...just to sit down and learn someone's story.